so thank you all and welcome welcome to
everybody both in this room and in the
other rooms which I understand are
filled to capacity welcome back for
those of you who were here last night or
during today as you know it's been an
extraordinary interesting rich
multidisciplinary multi adjective ole
experience so far and I think tonight's
conversation is going to be equally
fascinating and as you can tell they're
already comfortably added which is very
much in our style it is my pleasure to
now introduce professor Peggy Deemer who
will in turn introduce this evenings
conversation with Professor Hawkins here
Peggy Deemer is a professor of
architecture at Yale University she is a
principal in the firm of Deemer
architects and before that Deemer and
Philip architects she received a
Bachelor of architecture from the Cooper
Union and a PhD from Princeton
University the work of her firms has
appeared in dwell the New York Times
architectural record and house and
garden among many other publications and
articles by Professor Deemer have
appeared in assemblage praxis log
perspective and the Harvard design
magazine among many many many
publications journals and anthropology
anthology sorry she is the editor of the
millennium house architecture and
capitalism 1845 to the present and the
architect as worker in material labor
the creative class and the politics of
design
she's the co-editor of building in the
future recasting architectural labor and
rereading perspective professor Deemer
is the founding member of the
architecture lobby a group addressing
architectures historic lack of labor
consciousness and advocating for the
value of architectural design and labor
their voice has been in my opinion most
welcome timely and necessary her current
research explores the relationship
between subjectivity design
and labor in the current economy Peggy
welcome thank you very much for that
very kind introduction I really
appreciate it
it is with great pleasure that I will be
introducing the inter lockers for
tonight's evening mark gage associate
professor and assistant dean here at the
School of Architecture it was introduced
last night by Dean Burke and I won't
repeat that very very impressive bio but
I do want to however say how much we all
really appreciate the organization of
this fabulous event our new honored
guest tonight is jacques rancière jock
rancheras professor of philosophy at the
m european graduate school professor
emeritus at the university a party wheat
and one of the most influential
philosophers of our time especially for
those of us addressing the question of
the intersection between aesthetics and
politics and more particularly skill
still the intersection between these two
aesthetics and politics and education
one of the things that I hope we're
attuned to is that this is not just a
body of knowledge that in some way
characterizes our our speaker tonight
but is something that has implications
for what we are experiencing here now
because we are all performing education
for Ron Schara true education must be
emancipatory an objective that demands
equality not as an end but as a point of
departure Ron Schara was educated at the
coal normal superior where he was a
student of Louis Altos era with his
professor and other students of all to
Sarah
Rossi are composed and published the
seminal reading capital over the next
few years like many of all to Sarah's
students Rozier was an active member of
the Union desi teach all communists and
and constituted the famous circum out of
which
came the now canonical carry a
marxist-leninist and the career pro
analyst in 1974 after the break with all
- Sarah Ross here publish all toasters
Elsa Sarah's lesson and co-founded the
journal revolute revolution revolt logic
since then Ron Schara has published
numerous books including and this is a
highly highly edited list the Knights of
Labor the workers dream in 19th century
France the ignorant schoolmaster five
lessons in intellectual emancipation the
names of history on the poetics of
knowledge the politics of aesthetics the
distribution of the sensible the
philosopher and his pour the aesthetic
unconscious the emancipated spectator
mute speech literature critical theory
and politics and a thesis scenes from
the aesthetic regime of art and finally
Belet are the time after the work of
jacques last year like most European
philosophers psychoanalyst sociologists
and political theorists of the time must
be completely understood in the context
of French resistance in May 1968 a
resistance that was started by the
students was joined by the workers but
very much was organized around and with
the issues of the University at that
time 1968 became the occasion for him to
formulate his position on emancipation
when distinct from Alta Sarah Otto sarin
essence said that the entirety of the
contested French academic situation
ultimately rested in the quote absolute
condition of an inequality between a
knowledge and an AA knowledge knowledge
unquote that the function of teaching is
to transmit a determinate knowledge to
subjects who lack it and that this
knowledge this is Alta Sarah again
relies on the absolute distinction
between ideology and science Rossi era
argued that Algeciras assumption of
inequality amounted to a tautology which
is to say if you start out within it
with
of inequality you're going to end up
with inequality and that Alta sayers
dichotomy between science and ideology
is analogous to Marxist between those
who own the means of production and
those who are dispossessed throughout
his work in pedagogy Rossi era has and
had placed the entire idea of philosophy
as a judge in question for the simple
reason that it is constituted on the
division of mental and manual labour and
it therefore cannot rightly assume the
authority it had traditionally been
granted in other words philosophy itself
assumes the altos Aryan tautology
rancheras break from all Tessera spawned
a decade-long study of archives
chronicling the experiences thoughts and
voices of early 19th century workers
within these archives Roscoe has found
those who had begun to emancipate
themselves by the apparently single act
of claiming for themselves what
previously belonged to the upper classes
namely the right to think and an
equality of intelligence in other words
these workers assumed in existence
outside their material condition
according to Rossi era debates among the
various theoretical positions on
education equality ideology and state
apparatus the point unless they begin
from the premise and practice of an
equality of intelligence his thesis is
that equality must be assumed as a point
of departure and again not as a
destination the essential axiom of
equality is a starting point and the
structural considerations that follow
form the kernel of his thoughts on
politics and aesthetics the 19th century
workers as I'm sure you probably all
familiar with from his works sought out
the proletarian poets and artists who
are able to articulate their longings to
move beyond the unyielding
predetermination of their own worker
longings aesthetics is the prior
condition allowing for an assumption of
equality which according to Ron Schara
have only one to practice the community
of equals more recently Ron's chair has
written on the topic of human rights and
specifically the role of international
human rights organization
in asserting the authority determine
which groups of people again the problem
of the masses justify human rights
interventions here to the aesthetic
dimension acts as a marker defining
subjectivity it is this without with
this foundational faith and anesthetics
that makes raw quality are so central to
this symposium please join me now in
welcoming him to the conversation that
we're about to hear
so the framework is we're going to have
a discussion and we'll leave plenty of
time for questions so I don't manipulate
and then a peláez shocks time here but
we were speaking earlier and I stand
it's your first time speaking in an
architecture school so welcome I wore a
tie with French colors to put you at
ease your relaxed is the okay so I first
of all I just have to acknowledge that
we're going this is a kind of experiment
and the focus of this symposium was to
try to elicit new ideas not necessarily
rehearse old ones or validate existing
ones and so we're going from French
continental philosophy and architectural
theory and architecture and as such
we're kind of bringing together
different intelligences and I have to
admit when I was preparing for this for
the last several months I kept asking
myself what are you doing putting
yourself on a stage with Jacques risiere
but there's an asymmetry to quote Elaine
Scarry talk from yesterday and then I
just realized I was reading the work of
runs here and one of the things he says
is that there's not a hierarchy of
intelligences that all intelligences are
equal which was the reason I thought it
might be okay to do this but in that
sense we're not looking for the answer
to aesthetics politics architecture and
art in one evening
I I think Albania may be disappointed
because there she's not going to be able
to take anything that can be immediately
useful to scholarship but I think of
this less is having a big bonfire that
you're going to warm yourself around and
more looking for little embers that you
might take home and encouraged to grow
into something so in that sense we're
having a conversation looking for
opportunities and openings where like
Timothy Morton said worlds come together
or Elaine says where Beauty opens a
a door into another dimension and
opening into another dimension so we're
looking for those points of contact I
wanted to mention that I will actually
just wanted to start and talk about the
kind of scope of aesthetics and one of
the things that I had noticed I put
together compiled and edited a book on
aesthetic theory in 2009 and one of the
things I noticed was that one of the
things that authors tend to do and
philosophers thing to do is kind of
establish the distance with which what
aesthetics operates so Kant has a
certain idea about a disinterestedness
that you need a certain distance from an
object or in order to judge it
aesthetically that you can't judge a
plate of food as being beautiful if
you're hungry that you need that kind of
distance and Burke and Aristotle talked
about the need to be situated so that
you see the entirety of a thing that you
can't be too close to a thing for it to
be judged aesthetically Oscar Wilde and
Walter Payton really defined the
movement of aestheticism which was
separating art from the marketplace and
from industrial influences so that it
was this protected little regime of no
contact and no distance to everything
and I think that largely when we talked
about aesthetics today at least in
architecture people think of it in those
asceticism terms that what would you do
well you know what do appearances have
to do with architecture what does
aesthetics have to do with architecture
it's seen as a frivolous kind of
afterthought that's not really attached
to the real meat of the problem the
reason I think there's architects
developing an interest in Ron Sears work
including Michael Young and Keller
myself and a number of other people many
in this room is that what he did seems
to be a massive expansion of the concept
of the aesthetics to include things like
politics and it becomes conflated with
the discourse of art in this really
interesting and deep and complex way so
I wanted to start out with the kind of
defining question of if we're not going
to define aesthetics as a discipline on
its own or as a particularly
of art can you kind of give us a big
picture of the scope of your idea of the
aesthetic today okay but the first first
to say thank you for inviting me and
thank you to Peggy Dean Beamer for
introducing me and thank you to the
school and to all of all all of you well
I will I will speak you know what your
you'd certainly know about our well
while speaking about equality or
inequality you know what I absolutely
incompetent in architecture so in a way
you know where I am I would say in the
bad position you know I love that want
to feel the Sun I so we should okay so
so there is a K way of seven form of
Equalization perhaps I don't you know
but well but basically you to speak
about to what aesthetics may mean today
well I must say well you well we'll
remember you know but for me you know
what aesthetic is not aesthetics it's
not you know see the philosophy of of
the theory of art the appreciation the
appreciation of art and so on you know
and but Bill and so not that another
tour some kind of attitude of distance
or it results in an attitude of distance
you know we must try to understand what
distance with what should result from
what you know but they they basically
what I must receive it for me you know
well my understanding of what the
aesthetic means is based on to fact and
to factual or no first you know let us
let us impetus for me the ground meaning
of the aesthetic the aesthetic you know
you know I think originally has no
reference to other such because
aesthetics aesthetic you don't mean
doesn't mean what is you know related
what what is whether to outward confirms
art but what concerns sensible
experience and sensible experience of
the only mean you know sensuous
experience but the experience of a
common world and and so the the
aesthetic problem in general you know
it's not at all about beauty you know
it's about the existence about the
experience of a common world you know
and who and who is who is a with able to
share this experience you know
that's
why you know for me you know what
politics is aesthetic before before
arcane but before art in a way you know
because it is in politics but the
aesthetic question you know well you
know what wage it was the first time you
know because precisely the question is
you know what what kind of common word
state where politics constituted and you
can share who can show you you know we
can take part in this world when we all
know of course we all know of course you
know that precisely you know the
question is who can can be a political
political subject you know well
relatively to is sense sensible capacity
you know which you me you remember you
know Plato says you know that of course
workers cannot do politics because they
must live because they have no time
because they must stay in the workplace
and it is clear you know but this time
that the our bonds are the up not you
know is in fact both kind of material
and a symbolic or position it's not it's
not what they really learn there was a
very like time it is but it is worth
there a definition to be though to be
those of no time and so and so we all
know how to Thomas the questions of poly
relocation of politics is really the
question of demonstration of capacity
politics politics we are gained when
those were supposedly at low triangular
to do politics soup at the halftime take
the time that the applaud at what is for
me very important to know in the idea of
the object static and the object static
contraction or is always this thing you
know doing what you cannot do here you
know
implementing a capacity which is denied
to use it is the same thing you know
we've always the older you know how to
tell you know position you know which is
supposed to ground new politics
opposition between those of the draw
only allows you to express pain or odd
or draw you know and those who have the
speech you know
which which allows to make to make
arguments to discuss etc and so and so
busy and so basically you know which is
the promise of first level you know of
understanding you know what the
aesthetic means you know the aesthetic
is about sharing of sharing of common
words this is the first this is the
first point now we all know that at the
same time you know very kind of
historical you know determination of
aesthetics of aesthetics you know and
body first the adjective you know and
that aesthetic at a certain point you
know also which can't be so means you
know relation to a specific experience
which is the experience of the beautiful
and specially a beautiful what is
interesting we I think is that with the
emergence of aesthetic objective of
aesthetics you know is in fact you know
exactly at the moment eject eject
emergence of our as such we we know that
you know before in fact before
aesthetics
before aesthetics you know art did not
exist as a spirit experience you know
out mentally lower scale mental skill
mental know how you know and you know in
the old tradition you know there was a
there was only loss of exception there
were fine arts and Fine Arts where art
precisely which were not which were
which were not you know of course part
of the univ of the technical world but
that we are the still november
techniques but techniques destined to
the pleasure of a certain category of
people namely men of taste you and we
must think if you want to think well
they were what was done by by by by
account you know even with the idea of
disinterestedness you know it's not at
all you know instituting or separation
but in a way you know suppressing the
separation because whenever there there
was in in the 18th century Voltaire said
you know man of man of taste has not the
same senses you know as as an other
white man you know so so there was this
division you know kind of at the same
time physical and symbol and sabbatical
division and what come to what Candide
in a way you know was to Institute you
know as
judgment of the test of those worth
noticed who as a kind of universal
capacity and this is why you know
aesthetic aesthetic you know did not
never define they were defined some kind
of distance you know but but on the
other on the other well you know
opposite your opposite meaning deposit
meaning you know it defines something at
you you know art is doing more
electronic art works that art art
concerns human experience and general
and implements implement a human
capacity in jet in general you know and
I think this is very this is very
important you know and this is why you
know there could there could be this
kind of strong link you know between
political revolution and aesthetic and
aesthetic level aesthetic revolution you
know because because we're precisely you
know the obvious static revolution was
an idea of implementation of equality
implementation of this equality of his
equal capacity administer yeah I just
wanna jump in the one of the things you
said is I think one of the most lines
that most stuck with me as he said
social revolution is the daughter of
aesthetic revolution yes oh yes yes I
say I know and I said I said it you know
because what was yes that's the truth
but I'm Michael and I want to read a
quote from one of your books where you
talk about the specific example or as I
think is really illustrative especially
for the audience but he writes or I
can't remember for you this was a speech
or you'd written it but you said the
laborer stops his arms in order to let
his eyes take possession of the place
his disinterested look means a
disjunction between the activity of the
hands and the activity of the eyes we
can call it aesthetic experience and the
stet experience is not the experience of
an aesthete a drawing art for art's sake
quite the contrary it is the
redistribution of the sensible a
disassociation of the body of the
platonic artisan whose eyes are supposed
to focus only on the work of the arms it
is a way of taking time he does not have
this is what emancipation first means
and exercise of a quality that is an
experience of dissociation of the body
space and time of work so in that sense
aesthetic for use in this particular
example is creating an opening or a
small tear in the distribution of the
the sensible which this worker is
intended to be existing within yes no
because you know what
the yellow ARCIC restriction of the
sensible as each you know that but when
you are work when you are a worker or
when you of you with this means that you
are you are the ends you have a view of
the highs you have got the years you
have you've got all the senses you know
author of the worker you know and and
also of course the mind of the work and
so and so what is important what what i
found important when i was working you
know under nineteen 719 century you know
workers emancipation was precisely the
aesthetic moment in emancipation the
moment which is i say a moment of moment
of dissociation not only not only saying
not only sailing you know that workers
are men you know like any of no but but
demonstrating demonstrating the capacity
which is a capacity besides that the
disinterested judgment you know and i
try a level of corporate there were when
i wrote you know there was of course the
famous you know book by your broad you
and do on distinction so critical
council saying while what the luke an
account one who wants to to make this
distinction you know between the between
the taste of the ordinary man you know
you know just carrying you know for wild
and entertaining why what is pleasant
after all i like this wine okay when no
one and you know and experience you'll
obvious state no I think I put too much
evaporated the control to control you
know but really well inventing a kind of
aesthetic dimension in one's existence
you know was part really of who was
Battle of workers emancipation and the
weather so
what we are you know a face is my basic
device which is my basic idea idea you
know about the aesthetic but in a way
you know says the aesthetic is political
before be there before being artistic in
a way to no and but art you know but up
you know to operate it you know
aesthetically you know asked to it as to
produce a very different effect you'll
observe after the effect of the
technique producing and effect or
producer producing tzer's proposing the
pleasure you know off a class of men or
of men or women of test etc that's why
there's that paradox between aesthetics
being an egalitarian pursuit versus one
that established hierarchies I mean
historically it was defined as something
which established hierarchies and you're
I think one of the things that I feel
when I read your work is that it's it's
like the ground is dropping out from
under us like the kind of you say
inequality can only do in equality but
there is no path from inequality to
equality but equality is an absolute
assumption and that's that's a very
strong claim especially when you're
talking about aesthetics as being the
tool to manifest that but I wanted to
ask about the if the relationship
between politics and aesthetics is a
core feature of your work and you've
talked about the politics of aesthetics
and the aesthetics of politics I wonder
in this redefined frame of the aesthetic
what would what would what would
activism mean within that framework yes
women I think it's it's central it's
interesting because while various idea
of the aesthetic ask contemplation you
know and opposed you know to activity to
act upon to activity and of course those
diseases idea but but aesthetic
disinterestedness you know free play
free press of faculties I encountered
cetera et cetera
while this means of course the opposite
of the action action you which is
supposed to transform the world so what
I think
to think about the relation between
aesthetic aesthetic and activism we must
think about action itself you because
the first first first function for me is
that you know the aesthetic doesn't mean
kind of destined from action but a kind
of in of in a split of enough split of
action and this is all basis what is I
think clearly you know announced by
bygones you know that's the effect
meaning the feeling of the beautiful is
not the effect of art so so what is very
strong means experience but aesthetic
experience is not the product of a
technique you know define defining its
end you know and programming and
programming its end but the first point
alone and second to know about action
itself you know while there is always
this kind of a play of call to action
it's a terrible well under this kind of
suspicion you know suspicion about those
about council cans free play or shellers
play you know but whatever what does
this mean is free play and always play
no it means the suppression you know of
the of the Opposition of office of an
intellectual integral or and absent and
under under sensitive in the sense of
power it means the Oviatt means the
suppression of the opposite of the
opposition you know between an active
power and the passive power so what is
at the core of the aesthetic effect is
the suppression of the is a very
opposition the very opposition between
you know active men and passive men and
the between active men and passive men
you know people who people easily forget
it
but it was well it was deeply and cold
you know in the hierarchical tradition
that was your break with I that was your
break with alter sayers a the kind of
idea of the elite scholar leading the
ignorant out of their offering yes but
it's not only you know the elites you
know against against against age of
eighteen around you know was he reacted
the active men were supposed to be
live interview we're really in a while
in the universe of ends you know when
you choose ends or even you you can you
can really you act only forces only for
the sake of acting of deploying you know
your capacity you know and again and you
and there was this strong opposition
between active and passive MnPASS
achievement was we are not to be people
doing nothing no they were the work
better but but they were they were
passive you know because their activity
was supposed to be only you know in the
realm of of immediate needs and of the
satisfaction and so well I think what is
important is aesthetic activism you know
it's you know the core the core
aesthetic activism is this kind of the
strange strange you know conjunctions of
activity of activity and and an inactive
in in activity you know and in a way to
give you know I was actually going to
ask about that because one of the things
you do is you've written about dance and
cinema and not as the apotheosis of
movement but sometimes it's inhibition
that I wanted to ask about scaling that
idea up to an urban scale to get into
maybe kind of a little spacial
discussion that one of the things at
least in terms of the urban and the city
relative to philosophy is the situation
aside the derrive a where you misuse the
city in a particular way what you want
some of the things you've discussed are
not taking urban action but inhibiting
it as an act of politics oh you've
referenced the Istanbul standing man or
it could have been the Beijing tank man
or Occupy Wall Street that there's a
kind of political power in the misuse of
what the regime declares an urban space
to be in terms of the distribution of
the sensible but I guess the question
especially for people who design is the
political action always the misuse of
something that exists or can those ideas
be inherent in the process of the design
is it always is a political action
always come after the thing already
exists or can a political action or
intent
exist within the process of its creation
well it's a it's very questions well
it's a rift it's a big question of of
course yeah let us let us say well we
can't say what if we if we think in term
of space you know well I think but so
the Bears of the basic and Lauren thanks
kind of exemplary you know political
action you know is a barricade you know
because para Kandinsky blocking the
streets and blocking the street drugs to
the Barry Cadden 19th century barricade
you know well is it is not it is not to
use for military or military point of
view from my point of view in all
strategists said well it was it was a
mistake because if you block if you
block the street okay the governor so
this is this is this is a war you know
against the government against the army
but it's also barrier you know know that
prevents you you know tool to go to go
forward to move you know so but well as
the barriers of the barricade is kind of
wall occupation occupation you know of
the of the street which which is that at
the same and at the same time is a
constitution of an over people so kind
of negation of the separation of space
you know in fact blocking the street and
and it was still the same what is the
same with the occupier with the Occupy
movements you know and so and so on you
know in we blocking the streets it means
well it means well in the passage in the
Pacific where you know we're you know
we're really subverting the normal use
of street normal use of the street is
see actual essentially saturation and
the wall and back and what was what was
important you know was you know the was
the decision you know of staying of
staying instead instead of of working
you know and it's interesting because
this kind of subversion is also a
subversion of the normal way of doing
politics normally you know doing
politics with this means for instance
making the postal protest in the streets
you know and so there is kind of I would
say a kind of relation between you know
so normality of your urban space and so
the normalization of
article protest and well and variously
and various these moments you know when
being in mobile you know becomes becomes
a performance and what is interesting in
the case of the standing manual is that
well what he what is a performer you
know but he's performed his performance
you know consists in doing nothing in
doing nothing and and and the
performance precisely produce this
effect of disorientation that police
doesn't know what to do no he does
nothing
oh it isn't nothing so there is no way
but there is no reason you know to our
to our esteem but what's and so and so
there's a kind of the best elation you
know also of the Paulino state well okay
but I think interesting you know about
architecture is an possibility you know
of the design of the design you know
being being on the very day from the
very beginning you know a kind of
subversion of the urban space you know
well is that well in a way you know the
well in a way that is kind of opposition
between two ways of a fee you're
thinking space you know because in I
think I'm I'm struggling when I wonder
who from the for from the outside I'm
struck by this kind of obsession of so
many so many architects to well well to
mobilize you know to mobilize the FDR
talk about architecture must not members
no more you know do solid feelings and
broker and bloggers face but but
magnetically it must make you knows was
a space medallion and it's it's quite
fascinated by the fascinating I think
what I was looking at was project but
were made for the fall so so being out
of architecture you know the projects
you know for Detroit you know and I was
very I was a was a quite striking no
barrier by you know this kind of
obsession you know with a building you
know the old post you know and then you
see the old post is a barrier you know
separating separating the city dividing
the city from your top on the river a
euro and we must say we must go go
across you and and Andrew and Ramez Oh
memory
but average strength of trans friends
projects also having some kind of
spiraling and spiraling your building so
like parking you know with the ideology
but this parallel spiraling bear
building will engender new spaces and
genders you know and then also to know
of cultural amenities but also create
some kind of movement and there is also
another is also an a well having another
project with a lot of of pavilions of
pergola and so on Europe so as to create
a kind of indiscernible it herbs inside
and the outside you with the idea that
people that people must move you know
while over well I also I was trouble
also you know by you now is the interest
you know architects for all for senior
resident says you know which idea but
what about the senior must not relax you
know but it must be activated as much
activity what well ok reverses to see
but I think that we're very the two to
Davis kind of a about control of
contradict and where was a child about
the times I think where architecture
what we want to conserve has always been
in a way with clear of clearing of
clearing space of clearing the streets
and of course it was the first to know
with urbanization you're of course on
mobilisation against lower can still
grew you know switches tweet were you
know but - and of course whatever but of
course but more widely you know I think
well all architectural or utopia
doctoral projects where project of well
of tweets but cannot but cannot be
blocked you and well it's it so of
course resist a massive example real
awful Affleck obviously but also you
know if we precisely with Situationists
you know there were all sorts of
projects of constant and oh and also
this was a kind of project you know
nothing nothing and Bronx nothing can
blog and think the very so for me this
is an interesting and interesting your
own the opposition is a utopian strategy
just a speculative redistribution of the
sensor
well no never nope I think not very
strong market oh well architectural
utopia you know a free layer you know
with creating of creating the space of
other space of other specifc of
equality you know by creating a space of
mobility of space space with no barriers
you know and and I think it comes it
comes again today what I was I was
trying to Luber because I had to read I
had to read you know what to prepare to
prepare it all this discussion you know
so a lot of text you know awful
architects about architecture today you
know and I was tried by this kind of
catchy concept of porosity porosity
capacity so and when I did where and
where I think in general saturated in
saturator you know of the object of the
exhibition as a billionaire you know
after some some restrained remarks you
know seeing that too but a city with
porous walls you know is a city that
promotes equality well if that comes
from I one of the what we had talked
this summer and you had looked at
Michael Hayes book because we were
talking about architectures critical
history and I think that that porosity
and architecture comes from really the
Frankfurt School the idea that the
architects job is to reveal the
inequalities or reveal the social
problems by this type of porosity by
creating active openings where people
see problems and you've been very
critical of the Frankfurt School and
very critical at that idea of raising
awareness that raising awareness isn't a
form of action it's just raising of
awareness it doesn't require action and
I think architecture largely is still
modeled on being socially active in
terms of raising awareness of a problem
which i think might have be a lot of
what you've seen but and I think that's
one of the things that this particular
symposium is interested in confronting
this history of architecture showing the
problem of showing poverty of showing as
opposed to having another mechanism and
I one of the things I had read in your
book that's very coincident to some of
the things that we're talking about
particularly Michael Young is the idea
of a strange mint and you have this
beautiful phrase where you
talk about estrangement as the
subtraction of meaning the giving back
of innocence to the capacity of seeing
which is a very different thing than a
critical intervention it's not revealing
a problem that you see it's revealing
meaning which allows you to rewrite some
new equation or some new distribution of
the sensible so I wondered what role
estrangement might play in your idea of
reconfiguring those distributions of the
sensible well I think you know what they
say basically you know the relation of
the sensible it means you know when an
art does always something of something
you know else you know when it's proper
business you know and in a way
ventilation also means you know but you
but you are not doing only your own
business but also but the artistic if
the aesthetic efficiency is not the same
as the artistic addition say the way you
know the aesthetic efficiency means that
you don't exactly know that you not
exactly no you know what but we want the
actual what will be the effect you know
of what you of what you are doing in
okay so and so a architecture you had
always been at the same time you know of
course while making buildings buildings
and planning and planning down tight
cetera but also you know make it by
making all kind of projects of project
of you know of kind of fancy
architecture like for instance early
sixties pool ponds you know or to look
advantage protectants Tribune's things
like that you know which really is
creating not not buildings but symbols
of the new life why I will I've always
been fascinating in herbology by the
wall of the oblique line you know in the
in Soviet or in Soviet you know
architecture you know you observe of the
very beginning of the revolution as if
it was a matter of creating the kind of
space which which is no more articled
space you know otherwise this kind of
row row you know towards the sky towards
the future also which may mean that
people are equal they are because they
are inhabiting the future you know and
no more inhabit
you know the president of operation or
the president of struggle well so a
member to be this means that
architecture has always taken also taken
up the idea of being a kind of
instrument for a rare form of perception
or service architecture is supposed not
only you know to construct you know to
construction you know units Rabia for
for inhabiting but really constructing
new senses of seeing seeing working
acting your feeling at cetera and what
is in familiar with a strange mminton
anyway this is what this census means
but what is interesting with a strange
mental if a very beginning Louis friend
request it was defined by you
so by skradski you know as the proper
operation of art really within the
object from from all the mechanisms you
know mechanism automatism of perception
so a strange meant it meant at the very
beginning while saying is a saying the
thing with no interpretation you know
and and critical and critical art you
know critical art or critical critical
turn on you know wanted wanted precisely
to change the very meaning of
estrangement view so so vaginal
estrangement means what something to be
to be interpreted you know it so it
could be interpreted you know in the
inner while it is own question away you
know seeds is something strange this
minute right something wrong you know of
advice and this something wrong
expectation you know and and you know so
so so this strangeness is suppose you
know so to bring to bring about
awareness and what about energy you know
for about for for fighting you know well
in the case of the Frankfurt School well
this function of Revelation at the same
time as more or less disconnected in
factory disconnected in fact from the
idea of giving energy you know fervor
for action it becomes Ray's becomes
really kind of position of of distance
you know so on no more you know no no no
no more you know you know
director director towards action but
forever to a depression of distance or
the distance and this is always B's with
this idea that you know but the strange
thing is a kind of weather later but but
what it will be Latinos is human in
humanity of the system it's the armor it
is the Armani
it is violence you know so underpinning
harmony and so on
and then this is a land of course I will
architect it is something which is which
is easy you know I will I would stay to
where to put you know in the form of
fiction of Ch our hero Fletcher a train
you know well in architecture it's quite
it's quite difficult but what does it
mean exactly you need to prevail Oh to
reveal something by the way of
architecture you know and and in a way
well and in a way what is what is very
very strange for instance with some kind
of vertical architecture of course I
like your losers the famous bro you know
India and Scofidio you know this is what
in a sense you want it we will but rise
nothing to be nothing you lose the
nothing to reveal you know and so so you
are you are expecting something and
there will be nothing you know and the
fact but that but you are but you are
bad but there is nothing is a critic of
the fact that we are expecting something
you know so well that doesn't institute
any change that's just I don't think I
don't think that it's to take any chance
you know that well but what is
interesting so is but in this in this
way architecture becomes a kind of of
critical critique of itself and also so
I don't I don't built I don't build
anything this is the first aspect of the
critique you know I don't make anything
you know maybe if I don't think they're
built and oh I built a thing which is
which is nothing which is just used just
just burbles just water you know and and
various vendors like they comment you
know by child reinforce a saying you
know what you go to the cafeteria and
you can drink is an argument because the
money munch is just water you know
etcetera etcetera but so and well
but easy and you know in the end it's
very difficult to know to to think that
something is what is really revealed by
this I think you well is it's it's
difficult it's difficult you know to to
reveal to reveal something by the width
of architecture by the ways by the ways
of desire and you know way I think what
this function of Revelation was a
burgundy kind of for me I see it from
the outside I kind of endless of endless
reputation of a so called functionalism
in oil as if you know as if you know
constructing non-functional
non-functional things you know was a
critic of self critic of architecture
you know as if as if in fact you see the
aesthetic project of architecture could
be you could be really you know just
epitomize you know in the idea of
functional because modernity is no is
not simply about about function about
relation between form and function
modernity is a kind of what of the offer
of a wider of much much wider project
yeah one of the things I was thinking
about when we were putting this together
is the way you talk about the experience
of spaces walking you said walking
standing sitting looking seeing I was
actually thinking of the audience and
the architect of this building is Paul
Rudolph who designed this and maybe the
19 1960 would probably be this room and
that was 50 years ago and he's
determined where you enter where you
turn left where you go down where you
sit 50 years after he designed it he's
telling these bodies how their postures
should behave that there's an incredible
amount of power in that level of control
over people's actions but I think a
frustrating thing for architects is that
that seems like an incredibly political
power but architects have come up with
really no way to harness it and
modernism had a lot of the ambitions
towards equality that you discuss but
was really a
did for a now a kind of luxury class it
ended it didn't produce the Equality
that it sought to and I think that may
have something to do with that
functionalism you talk about well I
think it's not too it's not so clear not
so clear because the first function that
would function as an ambiguous term you
know because you know will so as a form
follows function you know means we means
but architecture you know it does not
list in those destined you know to to
make beautiful things you know cause a
pleasure of estates you but its destined
to serve life and it is interesting if
you if you think I precisely of fresh
skin and watch skin you can say you can
say well it is a status is a Matata but
at the same time you know in a wherever
skin endorses you know the principle
here the principle that Prabhavati the
dignity of architect of architecture you
know is to be defined by you is to be
defined by the sense of life and of
course the question is how you define
life you and the extension of your idea
of your idea of life but that's actually
one way you defined architecture you
said it was you put in the past tense
with her I thought it was interesting
but it was supposed to build not only
buildings but a new way of it inhabiting
a new way of life that it wasn't to
reveal the problems of this particular
world but set the format for the world
that you want yes certainly well and I
think and I think but the actual idea of
critical architecture you know what
follows of one of those follows you know
so one's a the fails of failure as a
fellow you know of a project of an
architectural shaping the front supply
and instituting some former supporting
some form of equality because I think my
but really the core problem with
architecture is not firm follows
function but the idea that use
follows design you know and so unused
roasted onion and and in a way for
instance election is the region was a
critic precisely of the principle but
about that form follows from for that
user follows follows design you know and
and at the point you know it's but you
can you are doing this architecture you
know none for well you know you forms of
forms of architecture and urban urban
planning but we are totally opposed
neutral Corbusier you know and that
produces some disastrous disastrous
effects you well you know where we are
for instance we have a user famous cell
the famous you know example in France
you know of lagron bones on your part in
your courage loop and it was really
supposed to be something like the entire
Corbusier you know way of dealing of
dealing with architecture so so no big
no big deal no big buildings no straight
lines and or small small buildings with
with curved or with curved lines and
many colors you know one and under so
the different cabins of units you know
and under and and vast gerenian tomato
on well not now it is it is the worst
neighborhood in france this is the worst
people in france not because it is a
fault of the Aqua Terra architects
utopia you know but at the same time
there was this idea that well user use
is that can be determined below by the
time the budget design what the problem
I think with architecture or the quality
is very very what kind of double bond
you know what in a way you know
architects but I was with architectural
dreaming to promote to promote equality
food for food design and and for
building and one of the question is what
equality cannot be cannot your product
that is the first of the season this is
the first first point you know and but
and the second point you know that is
that in in fact architecture I think
this idea of promoting equality barrier
by design was based its itself on a
certain sociology you know I think but
but really well architecture was part
you know obvious kind of big project
which is project but was a project of
the engineers architects designers of
the backbones MoMA Bo house etc so this
big this big Pervis Pervis big projector
for reshaping of the forms of light but
this big project in fact was more or
less you know based on the idea that but
equality but equality was was was
already a kind of a kind of
characteristic of the social and
economic process itself you so so the I
agree with this idea which was very
powerful and I think in the sociological
tradition you know that modernity means
a kind of automatic and modernization
you know observed modernization of the
conditions of life which means which
means equality you know this is why it
was possible you know four loko Brazil
to do it ourselves at the same time you
know so cities for workers you know and
villas you know for capitalists you know
we would send material you know so with
the idea that more or less you know we
are we are heading toward certain form
of uniformization of conditions so so
architecture architecture I think also
applicant actual dream was based this
idea that equality comes comes you know
by itself know by the very process you
know of modern there is a very process
of Modern Life so in fact it was in a
way sir the talk villian you know
presupposition under even zero-sum
access to some adverbs of some access to
theory you know that equality is it is
marching but and of course we know but
it was not at all not at all that the
case you know yeah so but buildings were
suppose you to promote equality where
bears on the idea of an modernization
you know and now and now of course we
scary with this Volvos votes it is you
know arguing over just ghettos you go
forward for folk over for Crimea for
drugs criminality and and and now
terrorism but well it's not a critic of
architecture but the point is but it is
not a question of functionalism or not
functionalism it's really the idea this
kind of double relation you know or
double play with equality with equality
right it's architecture always a a lot
of your writing is about the different
regimes
aesthetics and it seems that
architecture would necessarily always be
a product of the dominant regime by
virtue of its cost in its complexity
that architecture do you think
architecture like art like art is do you
think architecture is possible of being
that vehicle that challenges the
dominant regime when it's generally the
dominant regime that's the producers of
architecture I think I think that well
there has been historically speaking a
kind of involvement of architecture you
know in transformation transformations
of the form of life in a revolutionary
sense you know but one so so it's not
only that reference parents and some of
your books you bear instrument well no
parent so it was not - well what writer
answer what was interested a very
invariance you know because not because
it was a champion of equality obviously
was not you know who but what did that
building do what interests me
yes apparent sense you know is well as
as a conception even you know obvious
big factor where you know and this big
factor at the same time is a kind of a
kind of temporal kind of temporal of
labor and and indicates you know only
even on society but it is not simply
architecture not simply functional you
know but it is part of a new
organization of life and I think there
is something but was shared in fact at
that moment by both by your Soviet
revolution original and by you know
German architects design designers well
not revolution original but share the
same idea I would say of a kind of
culture of use value you know opposed to
the culture based on exchange value and
exploitation you this water thing is a
dream certain sociological dream and
also certain dream you know sustaining
so the underpinning you know sort of
architectural design one of the things
you I like that I never understood what
we meant by the Barons part but the new
condition of life that architecture is
somehow complicit in the production of
condition of life romance we've written
about Rosa Rosa Parks who had in a sense
like there's two ways to go about social
well there's many ways to go about
social change but if you imagine for a
moment that Rosa Parks had two worlds
that she was occupying one in which she
couldn't sit in certain parts of the bus
and one in which she could and I think
the critical ambitions architecture
would say you know reveal the problems
of this world and show that inequalities
exist and I think what you're calling
for and what this architecture is a new
condition of life is that she said no
I'm not going to protest this world I'm
just going to live in this world and she
sat in a place where she wasn't allowed
to sit and that was an assumption of
equality on her part an assumption of a
new world that she wanted to occupy and
I think the question for many of us is
can architecture fulfill that role like
can architecture sit in the different
part of the bus and produce the type of
world who want to live in what I think
it's quite complete what's complicated
but I think well I think architects to
do up to give the answer you know and
can just say you know is to propose a
proper to propose you know kind of kind
of you know idea sustaining sustaining
such a thing itself you know well I
think the point it very very very really
know no reason you know and the no
necessity you know to real any quality
yeah and the basis of image but I
thinking and practice you know as well
inequality inequality you know it's not
something that exists because people
don't know about it
everybody knows about ballet ear about
inequality you know and the question is
not you know revealing inequality and of
course critical art critical thinking is
always revealing inequality being
inequality but what if I was not but no
I think emancipation starts when the
moment or at the moment when it is not
on we
revealing inequality but a filming
filming equality on inequality so making
equality live we know in the world of
inequality when I was thinking you know
well really if I have some minutes but
it's not architecture at all and I'm
sorry and when I'm thinking % about the
notion of activism no to activism is a
new notion what did you define you know
kind of in political involvement artists
law and there was an institute of
artivism but was created in eq baba yaga
like Tania Bruguera you know and and
what what what is about what is
fascinating what is fascinating and
think in her try an inner practice you
know is precisely the way of affirming
fashioning the existence of what doesn't
exist you know if you think of its
office performance you know that in a
clean with Athenians Whisperer attacking
with permission of course also reference
you know to the architectural dream but
it's also kind of performance
instituting free speech in Cuba you know
and it was first and it was first
performed as an artistic performance at
the Vienna observe en algún are in Cuba
you know and so the adrenaline weather
was a pair for a performance of people
coming you know to institute free speech
in Avenel and and one of the and one of
the persons you know image you know a
waiver is a wish you know but that but
in the future in Cuba you know free
speech fateful speech you know will be
no more in an artistic performance and
we nobody but she tried you to make it
to make it exist make it exist you know
and and a verb adverb that it was of
course but it was of course you know
private advisor them by the by the
police you know but what interval what
what interest me you know is is you know
the practice of Afghani face which
exists because because we exert it and
and nothing and not simply you know when
we are proved what doesn't exist
there is no way people know people know
about Fidel but there are no free speech
the same way that they they know whether
that varies
inequality right and so we're learning
and precisely I think the perhaps
aesthetics is about it is about this you
know it's ethics is not about produce
Connecticut revelation you because there
is all your artistic practice which we
kids which is still I think we are
really part of the presentative logic
you know so art art producing some kind
of effect of awareness modernization
energy etc etc and well all the non all
denunciation we delay we relations etc
etc and what which is in a way kind of
technique an attempt you know even if it
is a crazy attempt you to define some
kind of some some sort of technical
technical technical and ethical you know
effect of art at the same time and and
of course and of course the your you can
imagine many many forms of political art
you just destined to prove but there is
no free speech and to value and what is
I think it does is it becomes an
aesthetic affair you know what when
there is when when there is not a
demonstration of in existence but
demolition of existence uh-huh so I will
leave time for other than ask one more
question and then we'll open it up the
last question was about you've written
about disciplinarity quite a bit and
that's something that we offer of course
think quite a bit about here in an
architecture school with its own
building with its own discipline and
there's been some discussion on the
value of discipline there's certainly a
lot of discussion here is there an
architectural canon should we teach in
architectural canons we get rid of the
architectural the idea of an
architectural Canon and I guess the
question that might be interesting to
hear your answer to is you talk about
the poetics of knowledge and I wondered
how the concept of a discipline is in
conflict of a poetics of knowledge or
there's a relationship where one can be
transferred into the other like how does
one move away from a disciplinary way to
transfer knowledge from teacher to
student or one it is a very a very very
complicated you know issue
I think you know those oh well Leah's as
a point is you know that you cannot do
that the politics of knowledge is the
same thing as you know emancipation you
know it cannot be institutionalized you
know so so well it is always think the
same thing you know there is always this
idea but there should be some kind of
right way or a right way of practicing a
discipline right way you know of the
right way of teaching or white or white
for organizing you know education but I
know no because in a way emancipation
the official emancipation says there's
no there is no work there is no right
way you know there is no point of
departure and what is what is striking
is but so so so often you know many
reforms of education but want to be we
are a libertarian you know etc etc in
fact are still our entirely auto Italian
you know because they say this is the
way the new things must be organized the
services are real point of departure you
know one and you must not stop there
start you know teaching from this point
but from this point about be but know in
all ways I think the poetics of
knowledge says you know but you can
learn from a multiplicity but you can
learn from a multiplicity or you know we
really of power of places and and for
multiplicity of ways you know once you
know you have abolished you know the
idea but kind of special intelligence so
I think the question of knowledge and in
fact is a two-fold is a two-fold
question you they because they're beyond
the idea of knowledge and the idea of
discipline you know there is not
authorized there is not only the idea of
how you will transmit or did lower the
data but there is also a kind of
separation you wherever there are those
who know and those who don't know and
those and which means but there are you
know opposite para to two separate forms
of intelligence of intially of
intelligence and this is called the
problem and in a way it's impossible
it's impossible looking for an
institution you know to rarely to be
organized in a different way of course
you can do
of different things in an institution to
wait for it etc but emancipation you
know you cannot even suspect an
institution you cannot emancipate
institution you know you cannot really
you cannot really you know for instance
you know gather you know professors of
philosophy sociology etc law that there
are architecture fine arts and well on
the tell them okay do you think but
really you know but but really you know
your your your discipline your
discipline is a specific specific form
of knowledge you know with a specific
methodology and you know and specific
borders you cannot do you cannot do it
you cannot do it because it is where it
is their job so are you I know you I
think you had a European graduate school
you were teaching there and you about
their decision to grant degrees alright
were you hoping that in essentially be
like a university you were hoping that
it would become something different
is that the reason well you know incog
was not really so much involved you know
in the European graduate school you know
but well it might a world you open
graduate school was a kind of strange
institution you know kind of family
institution you know because it was all
led by one person you know but we
invited source also we invited you know
lost or so a lot of schools you know
great thinkers radical thinkers etc etc
source otherwise always kind of the
board of supporters always impressive
you know and what was interesting is
about wallows students were not well not
you know ordinary students but people
are you know involved in pregnancy
different practices of art of research
sometimes engineers and sometimes people
doing a lot of different things you know
and where they you know so not so that
they did not have a TV came of course
they came to two years reject or bad you
or eigenvalue but was part of course of
the absurd interests you know very
sterling but bad but at the same time
you know they where we Liz they were
really you know
in front of you on the basis of their
own research on Korea their own
curiosity and not you know and not to
where you know with the idea of a Bingle
of having you know big regional and so
there was a diplomat diploma what was
worse doesn't just always say do it also
problem you know to have to pay people
pay and look for diploma but well but
this was not you know and and so and so
answer they decided to create a PhD and
and then there is a kind of process of
normalization you know which also
affects use the profits of the last time
the last time was supposed to go so I
received you know six you know six
months before kind of God guidelines all
I get to do you know from the syllabus
and so on you know and I called and I
called so so the director you know and
so they don't know okay but that's fine
but I don't go see and he said and he
said no no that's not no there's no
point to note that but but I think my
father of course he you wanna know you
know to equal the twin it and it was
defeated so matin so now I think they
are de Plaza but very still a very still
kind of balance you with between people
who come just because they are
interested because they're curious
person because they're because of
questions you know really that come from
the from their own practice you have
many many artists and but of course one
if they wanted you want diplomas it
changes it changes or changes of the
landscape because precisely you know or
school University it's doing different
things at the same time you'll also
giving diplomatic is once in you and if
there's a kind of pressure position you
know that really transmitting knowledge
or transmitting thinking or thinking or
thinking you know together you know this
can exactly coincide you know where with
deliverance of a diploma but that's not
true no all right the legitimization
isn't required I think we can open up to
the audience for in full questions
there's some people with microphones
that will hand them to you if you have a
question
they just all learned or diplomas are
worthless they don't want to give it a
shot no I'm about to get resolved you
idiot
did you just raise your hand someone no
yes yes thank you and thank you so much
for your talk I guess this is in some
way carrying through the conversation
earlier today or the conversations
earlier today and I guess I'm I'm really
interested in the relationship between
activism and disruption maybe especially
in architecture which I feel like you
all have started talking about a little
bit in some way I want to connect it to
this idea of beauty that Elaine brought
up where say beauty is something that
arrests you in the street and makes you
stop and think and I wonder if that's
also connected to what graham was
talking about where the aesthetic is
another type of disruption that
separates the object from properties and
then the subject or the beholder kind of
steps in I'm wondering how that might
happen in an architectural space maybe
especially if it is like you were saying
mark beholden to a number of power
structures and sort of has to be
complicit in a whole system of a city
say in order to exist why it's hard for
me for me to say what architects you
know should you you know well I I
finally I think that's well it is a
problem of architecture is the same you
know as for any discipline you know what
with the differential over - of course
you know in architecture you know there
are real issues of Monet
power you know and affection however but
are not in over it over you know in
other films of course but well but I
will I really I really think you know
that support for for meals as a point is
but while doing architecture you know
must mean doing a lot a lot of different
things you know but you cannot but you
cannot think you know but you're you're
involve your involvement as activists
for instance you know is entirely is
entirely comprised you know in your
design in your way of conceiving design
so I think in a way you know architects
up one when they were when they are when
they are activists which also means when
they when they are well behaving
aesthetically in a way they do something
over so it is always a question of the I
would say to the side as a side effect
you know of the effect you will not over
place you know well I am well I was
thinking here I was thinking here it's
not at all model you Lord and not at all
none of what are the architects up to do
you know but I was thinking a year of a
group of architects you know they
constituted the constituted a kind of
group of architects to architects
sociologists photographers writers
actors you know this group were by
what's called you also pay up a room it
means and friends support for for
research for wizards about you many
resources you know and and basically and
basically they were working in the
so-called jungle in Cali
which means you know the place where me
where my god stay where I can stay you
know while trying white trying you to
which United Kingdom and what's
interesting you know in I think their
way of proceeding you knows is that they
when they will know that they were not
denouncing the situation of the migrants
they were not helping the migrants you
know with food cetera but they were
trying to create some candle you step of
diagonal you know between very knowledge
of architecture and their knowledge of
form and of beauty of
and the sense of inhabiting which is
already present which is represented in
the camp itself and Suzanne saw the
preparation of a lot of photographs of
tags you know - what - prober - to prove
you know what well there is always
aesthetic but it's always sense of foam
you know in the makeshift cabins you
know of the bell of the migrants you
know and and you know under and after
was that kind of extension you know of
the project because we decided to create
some kind of what utopian project in a
way but at the same time the given
project was kind of exact calculation of
the cost you know ante and we proved
that you know it was it was less
expensive in a rubber band destroying
account the gumption to come to
reconstruction losers or so the town
itself Callie you know the town you know
neutral near the camp you know other
kind as a kind of newer a new city you
know so so so so that was his plan of
the of a word of Cali becoming a world
city you know instead of becoming
instead of being you know petty
bourgeois cities univer near near
migrant camps and of course of course of
course so you know I mean I attend the
authorities here you know to talk to -
of course - to prevent eat gelato for
from being done but but what's
interesting is it's always this
application of the misogyny of making
exist what cannot exist you know or
proving the existence was not of what is
not supposed to exist you know and and
so there was a kind of an interesting
combination of of strategy you know of
strategy of reshaping you know as a life
with a strategy we've a kind of
political or clinical strategy because
what they are all strategy other all
strategies no not no not only not only
did they did they sort of the the
construction of a service plough dismiss
plan of the future city but also you
know they published it in a fake
magazine of the town you know with a
fake letter of the
the mayor you know and to fake interview
the French presidents you know it's
about the future future so I think
available for me your wallet it's an
interesting development and of course I
don't think it is or what architecture
and I want us to do you know but ever
what I just mean you know what - but
architecture master or architects not
architecture in general or mature
doesn't exist but of course architects
you know probably are to today you know
people people who can actually can actor
endeavor at different levels you know in
depth in different in different spheres
you know so while local can for trying
to we think - with what - within the
common word because we're thinking a
common word precisely you know involved
in multiple cities you know of
activities of different kinds thank you
i I'm maybe going to continue in the
last question or push it in another
direction but it does seem to me that in
the main talks that we've had from
Elaine Scarry to triple Oh Tim Orton and
Graham Harmon and yourself that there
are very different definitions of
aesthetics and in some way Lance carries
and really does are all around beauty
and the triple o around the charisma of
the object and yours around a
sensibility that pre-pre exists its
capture by aesthetic but not effective
use but both political regimes and but
it's behind that it seems to me that
what is really different because maybe
those aren't so different I guess that's
probably what I want to ask them either
they're really more similar than then
I'm now thinking but is a difference
between a notion of this subject and it
does seem to me that that in alliance
carries and in object-oriented ology
there is a sense
I'm going to get I'm going to trip
myself up here but there is a private
personal relationship with the object
and the aesthetic dimension is described
by what the subject and the object do in
a direct way but it's indirect with not
to consulting but with you the subject
is is a socialized subject it you can't
divorce that subject from a
socio-economic political context that
that pure subject can't have any any
direct relationship it's an object that
would be an absurd way to think about it
but am I getting this right in any way I
you know either my characterization of
the subject or the differences in in
aesthetics that we're seeing here well I
well I would well but probably my my my
my point of view you know one was of
course you'll give your a dinner you
cannot really I'm not interested not
interested you know in the relation
between a subject and object this
doesn't mean that I don't like you know
to to be in front to look beautiful
beautiful things all right like I like
you know I was I was at a museum
yesterday you know I enjoyed it you know
a lot of things know that that's not the
point but not the point you know but
while I was I was speaking of the
aesthetic relation you know other kind
of also specific occipital specific
relation you know which is not not a
relation to an object but rather you
know while a position the position you
know inside inside inside a set of
relations you know ones it is what was
what was you know reminded by by
marginal while about about you know saw
saw saw saw saw joiners retire you know
gurney you know you know in his works
you know and we know looking looking for
the looking for the window you know
taking a kind of aesthetic position you
know also observe landscape
you know dissociating you know so the
associate angel is get from the work
from the work of East Angelo which means
that well being the Inger being a
subject you know well means you know in
a way adopting a certain position you
know in well in the distribution in the
divisional occupation dissection which
is both won't material under and and
symbolic or you know and so and also you
know I think what is important for me is
that is it is reasonable position you
know between we between us in the
individual subject and a collective
subject Laurie in a way what in a way it
is in a way it is it is it is a same
problem and I think there's a kind of
aesthetic Constitution of a group when
there is a kind of disruption you know
of office space you know by people
gathering by people gathering in a place
you know but which we remember for me
really you know being it's a being
subject to me means you know operating
you know certain with distributors and
redistribution of the coordinates of
expiry of experience you know so I think
we you probably need to continue
questions upstairs with some drinks in
honor of Professor NC air thank you
let me say a few things and the people
in the other rooms as well first of all
mark thank you very very much and
professor on Sierra thank you for your
impassioned presentation much
appreciated I also want to thank
everybody who presented today there was
a lot of information and a lot of
passion in those presentations as well
this symposium will continue tomorrow
morning at 9:00 a.m. there are three
presentations and discussions over the
course of the day tomorrow the
aesthetics of activism the aesthetics of
the progressive and the aesthetics of
the other I look forward to joining us
if you were here last night or if you
are part of the Yale architecture
community you know we extend our
hospitality will we will be having a
reception upstairs again this evening
there are a lot of people so I welcome
you all and I appreciate in advance your
patience and are crowding in honor of
our visiting Frenchmen tonight's drink
is called the French 75 it's true it's
real it's all real it's an object no it
it was invented in Paris just after
World War one it is named after a famous
French 75 millimeter field gun which was
actually used in the war about which
it's kick that is the kick of the
cocktail was said to be equal to that of
the gun
it contains gin sugar champagne and a
lemon twist and although first created
in Paris the drink gained popularity
precisely for its exotic foreignness at
the Stork Club in New York so we'll see
you upstairs
you